this episode of star talk is brought to
you by curiosity stream this is Startalk
I'm your host Neil deGrasse Tyson your
personal astrophysicist
and on this edition of start talk it's
office hours which is another version of
cosmic queries we're just calling it
office hours because you can come in
with any question at all on any subject
and I got my man Chuck nice here yeah of
course probably okay how are you man
thanks for doing this okay it's always
my pleasure I haven't seen the questions
yet and you never did one days you'll
show me the question now I will not I'll
bug you in the street yeah so what do
you have you pretty funny
Tyson beat the hell out of a guy yes of
course you know we get we take questions
from all over the Internet no no
wherever you can find us and so we
always start with a patreon patron
question all right let's do it
and this is Ari Modi or our re Mao Dee
from patreon ari says hey I'm from Los
Angeles
some astrophysicists say there will
eventually be universe death when the
last atoms are ripped apart by the
expansion and we enter the big freeze
but we are also told a universe can come
from nothing and taking any volume of
empty space and waiting a gazillion
years matter can and does arise from
that void aren't these contradictions
why wouldn't something from nothing
happen after he death if that is a
fundamental part of how the universe
works
so now Ari Maui he totally everything in
so right now the temperature of the
universe if you put a thermometer out
there right and it
sort of could receive the sort of the
energy of the void okay okay basically
the cosmic microwave background right
that that energy gives you about three
degrees but we used to be much hotter
when the universe was smaller right okay
right we've been expanding and cooling
not fundamentally different in principle
the mechanisms are the same but when you
if you ever let air out of a bicycle
tire doesn't want still run powers of
course yes okay I do it all the time and
it's not even my bike I just walk around
Manhattan I sit bicycle tire and I'm
just like you know what expanding air is
is cooler than the air that it was
before it expanded okay so the air fault
you know going past your thumb feels
cool not just cuz it's moving it's
actually dropping in temperature by
expanding and so you the universe
expands and cools it's a thermodynamic
fact okay and by the way we can look to
faraway galaxies right whose light came
to us from a time in our past right and
they're measurements you can make and
show did that galaxy is feeling a warmer
temperature in its time then the
temperature that we measure today that's
pretty while it is completely why
because you're not talking about a very
a big source like that light source is
it's a light source yeah but it's but
it's ubiquitous so everybody feels it
right and there's certain so now how
exactly certain atoms where how kaliya
electron will move in a certain way to
do math it's in there you go bath of
light like that yeah yeah and swimming
sense a little more excited rather away
you know here that makes perfect so
we're not just making this up all right
okay all right so know I had listen I
just had the mixer no so and the as we
get twice as big that dropped the
temperature in half three times bigger
drops it to a third so there's a direct
the direct inverse proportional
relationship to that in rockport very
good for tional inverse proportion is
that so so it as this continues the
temperature of the universe drops all
stars will ultimately
as they shut off one by one Wow the
night sky look at that as they shut off
in the night sky yeah you can ask what
are we making new stars well we are with
the gas clouds that are still out there
right but then they make a star and then
that star dies so the gas get sort of
trapped up in stars that die alright so
then there's no more gas to make stars
then the atoms themselves decay and
ultimately in about 10 to the 30 years
or so which is a huge number
right huge number the protons decay the
very structure of matter itself loses
all integrity Wow and so the universe
ultimately dies not with a bang but with
a whimper right and not in fire but in
ice it Peters out that's Wow after I
said those poetic where'd you say Peters
out bet you got for me so this this idea
that you can get something from nothing
I just want to spend a minute on that
right if I can okay so if you start with
nothing and then create something that
has both positive and negative energy in
it all that matters is that the sum you
add them together and you get zero zero
that's it okay so you can start with
nothing yet have something if the total
energy goes to zero right so another way
to think about that is let's say you
have a level field mm-hmm and say I want
to dig a hole okay so they dig a hole
and stack the dirt over on the left
right so I keep doing this I can make a
mountain as high as I want right but
you're gonna have a hole I'm gonna have
a hole that hole I got a hole yeah so so
the what we're not sure about is whether
you create another universe within this
universe that has expanded right out of
that void our best understanding of this
multiverse hypothesis is that the
universe that's created is not causally
where we say causally connected
what's outside of it so you could in
principle have multiple universes
popping up into existence right but in
the expansion and the edge of what that
universe is you have no way to interact
with it so so there you have it what
stuck in this one we're stuck in this
one yeah that's other is too yeah that's
pretty wild
yeah yeah that's it well listen my
name's were right
yo re as a great question and took Wow
took us to the edge of the universe and
battle in space but in time could you go
to the universe without space and time
actually once Einstein put forth
relativity right where the fourth
dimension is time so that's weird why is
that no no one has ever been at a place
unless it was at a time no one has ever
acknowledged a time unless they were at
a place think about it if I say to chuck
I'll meet you tomorrow at ten o'clock
what's your next question to me what do
we do of course I give you a time you
ask where okay I say Chuck I'll meet you
tomorrow at the corner of 33rd and third
when when we know intuitively that our
path through life involves the
juxtaposition of space and time
we know that intuitively we just don't
think of it in those terms right because
they're measured by such different tools
it's a watch and a map right right so
but in fact they're conjoined and
Einstein formalized that statement in
his theories of relativity that is great
stuff you got it all right let's move on
to a another question
hey how about woody it's clearly this is
a Pixar Disney Pixar character who's
just writing it
what do you would like to know buddy do
lasers and solar panels work together we
could design and
build the components for specific
purposes of wireless energy transfer at
great distances with frequency on the
light spectrum would be best suited for
this task then how would you resolve the
problem of a 5 watt laser being a
dribble like Chuck at 3 a.m. after too
few many 500 kilowatt laser what ok I
think I think I got his point so what he
wants to do is I have any energy here
and I want to put it over there right
alright so by the way that when you
think about it is kind of like what war
is okay what is a battle a battle I have
energy here and I want to put it over
there right that is kind of what the
waging of war is all about mm-hmm all
right I have a bow and arrow
I put energy in the arrow and then the
arrow goes over there there's a bullet
has energy it was a bomb
there's a delivery mechanism all thanks
for this sound effects they're just no
way yeah so so I think they're what he
wants to is a he yeah yeah yeah what he
wants to know is if I have laser energy
over here and laser goes fast and it's
very directed can I just have a
catcher's mitt somewhere where I want to
deliver it right and then use it to use
it and then use it and its energy in
principle nothing stopping that right
okay except the curvature of Earth's
surface if you believe in around earth
so you can't beam hamp bend the beam
light and bending right okay
not unless you have a gravitational
force that will Bend therefore yes that
would works on a black hole you try to
send a beam of light it'll just curve
let me go around the black hole itself
so but on earth and sort of normal
gravity that we live in
no not so it has to be a line of sight
delivery right if it's enough energy to
be useful it's gonna be pretty dangerous
to cross that beam it's really serious
if it's enough energy to do good stuff
with it right you are enough energy
they'll do some real harm but cut you
enhance that
can be down the street see what's funny
about that one is if you were smart
enough to make that happen but you
didn't even think it through completely
and you know you actually do it and like
on the test run you got the catcher's
mitt there and you're just like oh my
God look at this we've actually figured
out a way to transfer energy over great
distances and oh damn we just killed
somebody
or or a more a more tragic version of
that story was let's celebrate and dance
and then they actually danced kills the
inventor of the your version has poetic
just that one so yeah so that's an issue
so it's so insulated wires I mean we
were kind of already do that with laser
optics electricity boom that's
information we send by fiber optics not
not and it's not self all right so
you're right yes it's a small amount of
energy but it's not it's not enough to
power anything to power anything right
and what we learned here's just an
interesting you didn't ask this but let
me put this in the in a mix okay if you
remember everyone's expectation of the
future as imagined in the 1950s and 60s
flying cars motorized walkways people
were thinking that energy would be very
accessible basically if we could takes
energy to fly cars but that's not what
became accessible information right it
became accessible it's so we're living
in information and it costs you nothing
energetically to send information true
and as a as a communicative species
information is height it's a highly
valued commodity mm-hmm
so we sent information around the world
that you know with no with no effort I
was yes a big effort but no the
investment of energy that that requires
is extremely low so so back then no one
imagined a world where the movie 2001 a
Space Odyssey yeah
the computer was this big thing in the
center
of the spaceship and it was controlling
everything
no one is imagining you're gonna carry a
computer on your hip right Plus
entertainment this was not because it's
information yeah and it distributed
information is what that is all right so
we do send energy but we send it in
wires and they're insulated so you don't
touch the wire and get electrocuted
that's the electric electricity version
of a laser right right yeah here's the
wire sending energy here go grab it with
two hands no you're not gonna do that no
now go stand in some water okay this is
the public just to have some assurance
one yeah let's have a few more questions
into this segment okay all right Zachary
spradlin wants to know this given your
vast knowledge of physics and yes your
vast knowledge of physics what are your
thoughts on a holographic universe okay
I've never heard anybody ask this
question this is okay yeah do you
believe the universe to be holographic
in nature if so do you think we should
be researching more about the perceived
difference between the particles and
waves or are we already doing as much as
our tools will allow what are your
thoughts on nature of waves versus
particles and this perceived separation
theory okay that's a whole other thing
let me let me start with the holographic
universe and cool I don't claim to be
like a total expert in the holographic
universe but I'll share with you what I
know and my understanding of it their
calculations you can do that shows that
in a black hole and the event horizon
that's the point of no return
okay that if you fall through that event
horizon all the information contained
within you gets remembered at that event
horizon okay okay okay
so that's a little bit spooky because
you can ask the question are we
something real or are we just some
imprint imprint is the name of some
other things that's real is real
that's correct that's it that's it
that's it's almost like the play-doh
shadows argument or conversation that
you have are is there some higher
reality of which we are just shadows
representing it and so it's it's a it's
a spooky idea that has sort of
theoretical tap roots mm-hmm but I
wouldn't know how to test that maybe the
folks who came up with this have thought
that through but I'm not there right
with them on that I don't I don't know
how you would test this but mm usually
if the if the theoretical underpinnings
are working and they're based on other
theories that are well tested like
relativity and black holes and all this
you want to take it seriously
they didn't just pull it out of the
ether okay they were so so that's an
intriguing fact now waves and particles
of the duality yeah matter is waves and
particles right okay wait do you know
why an electron microscope works because
it costs a lot of money I don't know
really and why is the word electron in
the same phrase as microscope
microscopes use waves light waves right
okay well you can't kind of blow your
mind go ahead oh you oh you so you
seated I'm seated okay here you go
doesn't make sense that with whatever
microscope you're using you cannot see
detail smaller than the wavelength of
light right you're using to illuminate
the object that makes sense does that
make sense
absolutely because you're it's that your
blunt it's what that's what you're
saying okay as a matter of fact you
couldn't see it like no matter what
you're looking at if there is no light
then you don't see you see nothing so
you need some light so now you turn on
the light all right now if I'm using red
light red has a wave like a certain
wavelength right okay but if I use
wavelength like this shorter wavelength
so it orange or yellow or green or blue
okay of the visible spectrum blue or
violet has the shortest of the
wavelengths okay so if I have a violin
light microscope I will see detail
mm-hmm
better than I would in a red light
microscope right okay you'd also see all
the like really nasty cruddy stuff cuz
it's a black light and it's just like I
don't know it was that's if you go
that's if you go ultraviolet right if
you go to finally get your ultra go man
so so here's the thing it also means you
can pack more information into a certain
sort of size it's why blu-ray players
have higher resolution than regular CDs
right because regular CDs used like
didn't use blue lasers and who knew
streaming was gonna take them both out
CDs are what we use for you kids okay so
the point is an electron has a wave
associated with it that is on the rare
in the realm of deep deep UV into x-rays
so if you if you illuminate a source
with electrons
you basically have x-ray wavelength
light telescope that's very cool that's
what you have and you can see that's
what if you see pictures taking an
electron microscope
you seem that the fibers on the on the
micro it's that it's like naseous
because you're using the wave the wave
are the part of the product the wave of
the particle oh that's hot that's hot
and so my point is there is no meaning
for you to ask is it a wave or a
particle right it is but it is both just
cuz your brain can't wrap your head
around it doesn't mean it's not true
Wow we don't have to when I say you a
brain I mean our vocabulary our
awareness of a reality requires that we
choose it as this or is it at that is it
a book is it a chair is it you this are
your that right okay right this
we're forcing this in ourselves because
we'd like compartmentalizing this is
what part of the gender thing are you a
boy are you a girl which is it okay well
I haven't decided
you never decided so this forcing is
seems to be a deeply human thing right
but when it's time to understand the
family you know your nature not if not
doesn't necessarily have to be May it's
not cosmic nature yeah okay you got it
we got to take a break all right okay
we're in
Neil deGrasse Tyson's office hours on
Startalk we'll be back in a moment
hey if you want to learn more about our
incredible universe you have to check
out curiosity streams a curious world
series okay that means the name of it is
a curious world and it comes in a series
it's not about baseball they've done
some incredible visualization of the
formation of the universe I mean that's
assuming that you and I are in the same
universe you'll be able to see what it
looked like before there were planets
and stars what it looked like when the
universe was mostly hydrogen and helium
can anything hydrogen and helium okay
that was unnecessary
subscribe to curiosity stream right now
to watch it's just $2.99 per month and
for Startalk fans that first 31 days are
completely free if you sign up at
curiosity stream comm slash star talk
and use promo code star talk you'll get
unlimited access to the world's top
documentaries and nonfiction series with
curiosity stream go ahead sign up now
we're back on Startalk office hour is
Edition which is a way of saying cosmic
queries but you can pull that query from
wherever you want in the universe we got
Chuck here to mangle your name yes he
got a little better Chuck little better
I wanna I'm an educator I want to give I
think it's part of the charm of the show
the fact that I can't read alright I
can't figure out anybody's name alright
so let's move on to Kyle Ryan talk man
thanks brother Brian is two syllables
yeah Ryan is
not when I say it though right right
right calm down with time for theater
everything was it
Towson was it it was Jeff Foxworthy who
said in Texas there's certain words that
are like single syllable words with hit
multiple syllables yes like I won't give
a Shi that's like I have a friend he was
like if you're Italian Jeep is it sounds
like one syllable
but it's a whole sentence you know it's
a G yeah not yet you know but I'm gonna
meet otogi why is that if you're Italian
I don't know that's what he told me so
oh you meet Italian descendants speaking
like within a Brooklyn accent yeah yeah
I think pure Italian oh right sorry
no this would be right the Diaspora
that's how I got one no I'm saying now
yeah and wait then it's John know what I
am saying right do you know what I am
saying no I'm saying no I'm saying
nothing and Yami you all know what I
mean yep hi here we go I'm saying no I'm
saying all right here we go
how do you spell it you know em pasta
fee it's AI and I'm saying now say
nothing all right
unspell below you
[Music]
and if you're a black woman is the hands
gotta get all in there that's the same
thing you just win a higher octave well
the pitch actually connotes the feeling
behind it
so there's the affirmation was like baby
you look good okay and then it's just
like so okay yeah so so the pitch the
carries mean it carries meaning even
though he's saying exactly the same
thing but is it all in the pitch okay
that's good no that's good that's it
that's a dump that's a you are lying
through your lying right not better
known as Negro please there you go
here we go this is I got a word where
the pronunciation changes just by
capitalizing the first letter wait a
minute go ahead no you'll get that later
okay go I'll tell you no no make it a
tease we'll do it after the break after
next break after after the next break oh
that's a real team no keep you coming
back guys you gotta stay here now you're
forced you are forced to be here okay
here we go
imagine a planet orbiting close to a
black hole and experiencing extreme time
dilation
how would outgoing signals of
electromagnetic communication be
affected will we still receive such
signals would they be distorted and or
appear very slow-paced yeah no yeah it
still goes at the speed of light right
if the planet is outside the event
horizon it's not trapped and it's in
orbit yes it is in a deep gravitational
well there is very serious time dilation
relative to anyone looking at them they
will send out a signal and the energy of
their light as it comes out will it will
continuously lose energy so that by the
time that not speed I see it'll still
come out the speed of light energy but
if it starts out at a high energy band
of light by the time it gets out it will
be
very low-energy band of light
interesting yes so you're gonna get very
low low-energy see it so and that's
counterintuitive to what you would think
because you would think that it would
lose speed but you can't like you know
not like cannot lose speed but a way to
think about this is if I send a beam of
light there's a certain amount of energy
and I do that in one second let's say
right K but now I'm looking at you and
my one second is net sorry what you're
calling one second now takes an hour for
me okay did that amount of energy that
if it's packed into one second delivery
time has a certain intensity to it right
but for now it's taken you an hour to
send out that energy as far as Mike
watch is concerned that so the energy
gets diluted over that ascent from the
black hole interested so yeah it's
called a gravitational redshift right Oh
Ted we have a term there's a probably a
wiki page on it I got good people yeah
my my astrophysics my community I think
we got some of the best wiki pages
accurate wiki pages out there and by the
way it is it's a hard page it's not
agree with other Sciences I think we do
a good job you guys gravitational
redshift don't try to do on that wiki
page is make it easy for regular people
like me to understand gravitational
redshift alright that's a great first of
all that was a great question Kyle yeah
so thank you so much all right bring it
on let's go with an EC Hickman and
anyone's to know this she says I am a
teacher and a man you wrote for the
teacher
boom blow it up for the teachers and
Emanuel cos God are they making such a
sacrifice to just waste your life on
these kids you know I'm joking I my
mother was a teacher I have nothing but
the utter
she says I am a teacher and a manual
wheelchair user from time to time my
students and I wonder if a wheelchair
could be powered in space with
your works or perhaps they are ready to
get rid of me to send gender up the
space since fireworks are rocking she's
thinking about propulsion here he is
thinking about propulsive also what
having mobility issues on earth be
erased in space since there is no
gravity if you float around the space
station for example aren't you losing
your legs for the need to balance and
you know that's a great question because
people would think that in zero gravity
that your movements might do something
in terms of affecting the way you drift
about in zero gravity so what is the
answer there so first great question and
so I presume it means she has power she
has arm power arm to propel her wheels
right so that's a key element to this so
first of all in space you don't need the
wheelchair you have a wheelchair so that
you don't you're not on the ground right
so it in when I say in space I'm
referring to zero-g in space just take
that as a given here so if you're in
space generally people are not
maneuvering themselves with their legs
right there the spaceships or design
space station is designed to have grips
oh okay so every user relates they're
always grabbed and then and they swim
through the air I mean yeah exactly
and so you don't wanna go too fast
because you have to stop somewhere and
the other time and you got to like be
ready to stop right so if you have full
use of your arms and your arm muscles
you do you'll be doing what everybody
else is doing on on the space station
that's so cool so now the difference is
you won't be able to do some of the sort
of acrobatics that they do to show you
so for example one of them is they'll
they'll start rotating and then they'll
bring their knees up to their chest you
might be able to pull your own legs up
if you don't have using your legs you
just reach down and grab them but
otherwise they're pulling their knees up
and then they see that they spin faster
and that just have to just haven't
spinning fun like when an ice skater
brings their arms in they spin faster if
you bring your your extremities in and
you had a slight rotation before you
have a fast
- rotation and in case you were not you
don't feel nausea enough for being in
zero-g now you can just spin right and
then throw up right on these balls if
you're spinning while you throw up then
there's the name spiraling that's a
beautiful beautiful I don't think that's
it so now in the Rockets now so here's
the thing because I'm thinking in my
it's not about the chair
there's none I'm talking about what she
was saying if you put Rockets on a
wheelchair but on the wheels themselves
would you propel yourself through space
in that chair even though you don't need
it or with the rocket just spin the
wheel in place so what'll happen is
you're because the wheels on an axle
mm-hmm and so now you're putting
something called torque right onto a
torque is a force that causes something
to rotate okay
I've always loved the word work it's a
badass word yeah give me some torque
exactly the car folks all like what it
love yes it sort of pounds of torque
foot-pounds yeah it needs a distance and
I think sand the right because it's a
distance from the point of rotation how
many feet away and how many pounds force
to push it so what you'll do primarily
is rotate the wheel but there's
something called conservation of angular
momentum so if you're in space and you
want it to keep your wheelchair if you
sent wheels rotating one direction
something has to compensate and rotate
backwards okay so you push the wheels
that way and you'll just you'll just
you'll just rotate in the opposite will
be going an opposite to correctly
spinning around correct so what you want
is if there's a force operate on you you
want that this is inside baseball here
you want that line of force if you
extended it to go through your center of
mass right and that way your entire
system moves moving all at once all at
once if you're off the center of mass
you're gonna start rotating you're gonna
rotate yeah you have some movement
forward but a lot of that's gonna go
into your rotation and you don't want
you wanted to be stable right there so
there you go and you're what you want to
do is lose the wheelchair lose a
wheelchair now me together you don't
need
you don't need it yeah yeah very cool
and she like fireworks rather than just
those jet packs so you can take like
roman candles or whatever light it and
since that has a roaming camera is it
intermittent right so you can just
adjust it hold it where you quit where
you want and let it pull you and let it
pull yeah yeah very cool very cool I
don't want to go to space now I do we
have time for another one yeah yeah a
couple more let's do okay here we go
this is Jay did gaiter
Jay Decatur wants to know this what you
go with that drum yeah okay hey Jay I'm
sorry we'll go with that yeah so yeah
you know I'm sorry what does the merging
a black holes me for the future of the
universe could the universe eventually
if it does start a sort of contraction
phase be the victim of a collective
hyper massive black hole could we be
left with a singularity or a black hole
containing all the information in the
universe waiting for the next Big Bang
to trigger or does the universe have
more not-so-distant problems to your
attire black holes are not as voracious
as lore leads us to believe right
there's a black hole in the center of
our galaxy okay and it's just what we
call a supermassive black hole
I forgot they forgot the exact mass
hundreds of thousands of times the mass
of the Sun so I'd laugh at 605 but it
might be a minute I forgot the number
but it's large okay and the formation
mechanism is still a little bit of a
frontier in my field you can merge two
black holes if two galaxies collide
right and we've seen that happen wait
wait it's happening all the time every
day all the time and so as they collide
the black holes will ultimately find
each other
and then they will merge and then you
have a black hole twice as big but the
black hole is not reaching out if you
would not otherwise falling into a black
hole you're not gonna now start falling
into the black hole we are saying out of
drink it's not a toilet bowl right right
so we're not we're not gonna one day
blame a cosmic poop right man and so so
no in fact in the very distant universe
black holes ultimately will evaporate
according to Hawking radiation it's it
and it's a really interesting phenomena
so now okay what the phenomenon is okay
yeah so a black holes is very strong
gravity okay well how much gravity
doesn't have well you can think of the
gravity having a density of energy
because the energy density of gravity
okay in its vicinity every now and then
spontaneously that energy becomes
particles according to equals MC squared
okay I'm gonna do that just
spontaneously and you make a particle
pair a matter and antimatter particle
pair and they go in opposite directions
oh okay okay okay by the way they have
to go in opposite directions
so that the momentum cancels because it
started out it's just a pocket of energy
sitting there doing nothing right you
can't have to a particle just go in one
direction and nothing canceling out that
motion in the other this is like a
bazooka yes the recoil in the otherwise
the person right no to the next design
let me redesign that why do you guys
have 25 bazooka shooters yeah so there's
a there's a recoil of that to send it
forward gotcha
so it's same with the spaceships the
rockets that take off to you you recoil
at the back all the the exhaust so what
point was I making we were talking about
so the particle as it evaporates oh yeah
so what happens is so the energy density
spontaneously makes a particle pair one
particle falls into the black hole and
the other escapes right and that takes
mass away from the black hole and that
is the evaporation rates in the black
yes very slow
so that it's real but this spontaneous
particle you know basic talk walking
radiation is Hawking way to gauge call
so it's the dissemination of the
particles that are opposites and one
going away one going in yes and then all
of a sudden if it keeps continuing that
you glycol is gone it evaporates into
nothing to nothing
correct okay we we gotta take a break
glue you back for our third and final
segment when we come back you will learn
what words pronunciation changes just by
capitalizing the first one yeah yeah in
Neil deGrasse Tyson's office hours on
Startalk this episode of star talk is
brought to you by curiosity stream we're
back on Startalk cosmic queries edition
Neil deGrasse Tyson's office hours where
we take questions on anything that
doesn't have to be in a category MMA and
they're coming at they're coming from
everywhere everywhere chuck is helping
me out here Chuck keep it going alright
let's jump right I have to know first
you got to give the answer to the tease
okay I like words a lot okay so what is
this word that you can sorry capitalize
the first letter yeah and change the
meaning of the word completely
completely the word is I feel like I'm
on MPR the word is pol i Sh polish yeah
and then you capitalize it and it's
polish yeah so one is what you do to
shine something and the other is your
nationalism as importantly friend right
it's weird
it is weird has nothing to do with this
show but I don't know why I so don't
start a sentence with Polish polish your
shoes very cool very cool
let's go to fired or pop off fyodor
field or this FY yes yes either it's
field or yeah okay and last name pop off
Fyodor says this if you had to guess
where lies the great filter
first of all what is the great filter I
have no idea yet what he's asking in
this question so please proceed all
right okay let's there you go no no let
me hear the whole question that's it
what if you had to guess where lies the
great filter I don't know what the great
filter is I mean unless it's you know
it's a great fritter if it's good where
lies the great filter in my fridge
filter filter in my water the great
filter I have no understanding of that
question so we gotta go to Wikipedia
maybe maybe from that again I'll be able
to say something something okay all
right all right so in in that case what
I'll do right here is go to wiki wiki so
you help me out here in from wicked and
I'll read it to you they say it is the
great filter in the context of the Fermi
paradox is whatever prevents dead matter
from undergoing a Bo Jeunesse Janus a BL
Genesis in time to expanding lasting
life as measured by the Kardashians
scale okay I can say something about
this all right I just didn't know what's
called the great filter all I got from
that was Fermi paradigm so the Fermi
paradox was a question posed by the
great physicist Enrico Fermi right so
Enrico Fermi posed the question because
you can run the math you can say all
right how long has earth been here how
long did it take life to form how long
did it take what we call intelligence to
form now that we're intelligent how long
does it take to travel to another planet
let's say we have a spaceship all right
is it a generational ship fine so it
takes ten generations to get there then
you become pilgrims set up tent now from
there you go to two other planets
okay from each of those two planets they
go to two to four more from 1 to 2 to 4
to 8 so it grows exponentially
you can populate the entire galaxy with
intelligence
in a shorter time than evolutionary
timescales hmm okay you can do it in
like a million years okay or so right
okay yes and that's that's on an
evolutionary the doctors went extinct 65
million years ago so that's a very very
small compared with a lifetime of a
planet exactly so and especially the
future of the universe right so if
that's the case why hasn't it happened
yet and where are the visitors trying to
trying to populate this planet that
we're on so it's the Fermi paradox where
are they maybe they were already here
maybe we are then maybe we are them you
know so there's some religions that are
based on that that God is actually the
aliens yeah that's what you said that
was implicit in there so this dead
matter what they don't mean dead matter
because that implies was once a life
they mean inanimate matter inanimate
matter evolving to become
self-replicating life so the questions
may be that takes so long that it puts a
damper on this whole other process on
the all the other processes however that
happened really fast on earth okay
we went from inanimate molecules to
self-replicating life within a couple of
hundred million years Wow and once you
have life life was there for billions of
years so that's not really that long you
know it isn't right right so the filter
I don't see that as the big filter you
know what I think the filter is but
whatever urge you have to colonize
planet okay and then all your
descendants have that same urge right
there's going to be a point where
there's a planet I want to colonize oh
but you want to colonize that same
planet so then what do we do you know
you're gonna have a blood for you you've
got a blood for your fam with your own
family right correct and so it could be
that the urge to
to expand is self-limiting because you
will fight wars nestled yourself now
cancel yourself a very urge that causes
you to strike out and discover is the
same urge that destroys you in the end
correct
Wow right and their whole categories of
these kinds of problems in life for
example I don't know if it still happens
if you lose a quarter in the between the
base and the back of the seat in your
car right and you reach for it right the
act of reaching for it separates the two
cushions more and then it falls further
in see I'm cheap that whole seat coming
[Laughter]
we got one minute left let's do
lightening round go all right here we go
you know what this is an education
question so let's do it this is
lightning round Steven Donham he says
hey Neil love your show listen all the
time my question is about Common Core
math being taught in school it seems
like a waste of time the kids have to go
through all of these extra steps to get
the right answer when there were simpler
ways to get the right answer when it
comes to life and death and space
wouldn't it not be better to get the
right answer the fastest possible way oh
good question
okay I am NOT doing a lightning round on
that question okay it's too important it
is a very end with my answer to that
question of the show and that's why I'm
doing deep dive on educational
philosophy that's why I put in my recent
months well your education your deep
dive and I'm looking at what people said
what have worked what hasn't best
practice and I have come to conclude
with regard to that question okay what
matters more than the right answer
mm-hmm is the right question interesting
and taking a cue from Isaac Asimov and
an essay he once wrote called the
relativity of wrong the relativity of
wrong yes okay so here you go you're in
elementary school uh-huh and I have a
spelling bee mm-hm and I ask you to
spell cat
and you spell it ka T its marked wrong
right you don't get any credit for that
because the correct answer is C 80 but
suppose instead you had spelled it xqw
it's still marked wrong and that's so
much farther away it's so much farther
away than K 80 in fact you could argue
that ka T is a better spelling than C 80
you know why because if you look up cat
in the dictionary C 80 the phonetic
spelling is ka t okay but you got it
marked wrong right
so this urge to get the right answer yes
I don't want to diminish the importance
of right answers that has value but it
has less value than you think it does
because in exploration you have no
answers you're on the precipice of the
boundary between what is known and what
is unknown and you're taking a step into
that unknown and you don't know what's
there you don't even know what question
to ask I know it's there but yeah put
your pro you're probing you're poking
you're trying to figure out what
question to ask and so and most
questions don't even have an unambiguous
answer exactly okay I give you an
example
okay what's the diameter of the Sun ask
me that what is the diameter of the Sun
you look it up it'll say 864,000 miles
okay okay
fine but in what wavelength of light did
you make that measurement all the
wavelengths of light emerge from you
deeper in this R right okay and if
you're using x-rays it's bigger the
corona emits x-rays we found that out
earlier in the show because of the
different wavelength that's a different
wavelength so you have to specify how
high up does the atmosphere go over that
monsieur poirot of 62 miles 100
kilometers that's that we just agreed
because that's a round number in
kilometers
they're still air molecules above 62
miles that's why we have to boost the
Hubble telescope every now and then
because the air molecules just are
knocking it out of orbit okay so there
is no demarcation line it fades until it
blends with the interact with the
their planetary medium so we'd like tidy
answers but most of science is not even
about the answer it's about the general
understanding of what's going on and
then you take it from there
so no Common Core math is a good thing
it's got you thinking in ways that it
will enable you to tackle a problem in
the future that you have never seen
before and if you're in space it's not
about knowing the right answer to a
pre-designated question it's about
figuring out an answer to a question no
one has asked before right right so you
need the tools in the method and the
power of inquiry to accomplish that Wow
there you go drop mic that was that's a
very good answer I'm saying I like I'm
writing this up it makes sense it's
going in the next thing all right Chuck
this was good man always good to have
you yeah you know say star talk I'm Neil
deGrasse Tyson your personal
astrophysicist in the my office at the
time the creative at the cosmic rivet at
the Hayden Planetarium in New York City
part of the American Museum of Natural
History
and as always I bid you to keep looking
up
dance the curiosity stream for
supporting this episode of Startalk the
universe is full of mysteries as you've
seen in this episode well curiosity
stream has a video about the universe in
there curious world series see that it's
a it's called a curious world and it
comes in a series the animations are so
engaging I could have watched the video
with the sound off but don't do that you
want to learn something they show you
everything from star formation to
theories about dark matter and most
importantly how planets like Earth
formed which is important because you
know I live here on earth you can watch
it for just $2.99 per month and if you
go to curiosity's dream.com slash star
talk and use code star talk your first
31 days are free though they're right
now with over 2400 documentary features
and series to enjoy you cannot be
curiosity stream
you
you